[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's a Prof hi Walter hi Martin we're
back in the studio I'm glad we're back
in the studio yes yeah we had a good
time in Brazil yes took a few bugs with
us yeah no we brought a few bugs back I
don't know where they started but where
ever yeah yes but uh getting there again
yeah no just want to maybe quickly
mention the about our experience that we
had you know
sometimes it is
necessary to make personal
contact uh people are are really very
hungry number
one and to the times that we are living
in are not really conducive to Peace of
Mind
M and if uh you know people can be
reassured that no matter how bad things
get God is in control
yeah and if they can see that there are
some people who know how bad it is but
also know that God is totally
trustworthy it can encourage
them and there were so many interesting
stories and so many stories of hardship
yeah so I think uh you and I we spoke to
so many people and we realized
that God is picking up the downtrodden
oh for sure that that was it was one of
the most humbling experiences I've had
probably in my life yes Meeting those
people I mean there was one one person
there if you listen to to their stories
and where they come
from it's totally
shattering I mean this person as a child
was
lying in bed next to his mother when his
mother shot
herself and he was going to go to
orphanages of course and he ran away and
grew up on the
streets and today they're in the church
yeah God goes fetches them yeah I mean
we we were walking from the hall to the
where we at where we eat the eery and
how many people just want to say hello
not for because you are a celebrity just
to get a hug just to get a hug they need
a hug and and they will break down in
tears before you even say hello yeah
obviously there's a lot of pain in your
Humanity a lot of that and we need to
get back
to a state where we stop criticizing
each other and lift each other up and I
just realized when we were there that
yes there's a very big footprint that we
have on the online community but the
people that you
reach Jesus went also to people
physically he was there physic
physically so when you neglect your
church going and your fellowship with
others that's also not good people
should go out and meet people yes and
try and build each other up yeah so yeah
it was a very good experience very
humbling experience and uh it is
something that one has to you know
modulate because
it's very energy
consuming and we have to preserve our
strength as well so to find a good
balance is not always
easy and sometimes people expect things
that you're not able to
deliver because you're just so
inundated but
uh all those must just know that if we
cannot if we cannot physically
necessarily or always be
available at least we can have empathy
and know that people care and that we
can we need to pray but those people can
probably be
physical attentive to somebody else yes
and that's where I where it's important
it's always a double-edged sword yeah
help someone else and you will not fail
to receive a blessing yourself yeah well
one other thing that was very prominent
was
the the young youngsters the little
children the children they came there
they sat in the pews and they actually
took
notes and then they want the speaker or
whoever was on there to go and
acknowledge that he took not good yeah
now M if if little children can do that
mhm if little children can sit through a
a lecture series that goes for 1 and a
half hours sometimes 2 hours and take
notes and be on board with what is being
said why is it not possible for adults
to do the same I no the the attention
span of those children were amazing yeah
and they were there and I think it's
something that we can take we can learn
from for sure well God said that uh the
little children are going to play role
oh for sure we could see that at that
camp meeting we'll show some of the
material after this important discussion
that we're going to have so let's open
with a word of prayer yes let's
open our heavenly father we want to
thank you that we can do your work that
it's
still in our ability but we cannot do
this alone we need your help please we
ask that you Enlighten our minds and
guide our discussion and help us to
bring the message to the people in
jesus' name amen
amen it's titled almost there
yeah and the the picture I think uh
speaks a thousand
words you have uh the Ten Commandments
or two tables of stone at least with
writing on them representing mhm
something like the Ten Commandments
you have the Vatican and you have the
image thereof the
capital and uh it's fascinating how
accurate the Bible is even down to the
architecture for sure you can just stand
in awe stand in awe at this inspired
book that we are dealing
with and we are
in the tippy toes of Daniel aren't we I
believe with all my heart that we are
but we're also in the culmination of
Revelation chapter 17
yeah five are
Fallen one
is the other has not yet come
come and then there's an eighth one that
belongs to the
seven Martin these are all very very
fascinating
themes the them theme of seven
and8 for
completeness we are so very
close eight is also the number of
Christ if you take his Greek numerology
then his number is
888 and he is the
E because he had the resurrection and
the eight is a number eight is a new
beginning uh many people believe of
course that because of the Resurrection
that changed the
Sabbath but the law is immutable the law
doesn't change yeah it indicates a new
era that commenced and it started with
work mhm it didn't start with rest no it
end the seventh day was rest the seventh
day was rest so these are all
fascinating
things and
then there will be a resurrection of the
eighth but he actually belongs to the
seven so the number seven and eight if
you go through it perhaps we can do a
little study in a future one on some of
these
things but that refers to the
completeness of all things in Christ
seven is also the number of
deity and the new beginning is possible
because of the sacrifice of Christ so
he's also the eight yeah yeah so he is
the seven and he is the eight and he
belongs to the seven because he's also
deity and the counterfeit will of course
try to do the exactly the same thing so
he also is a seven and a
eight but that eight goes to destruction
that's it's the opposite yes and what is
the eight it's the fully restored
papacy with the same power that it
wielded before mhm and the kings of the
world will give their power unto
it and will do its bidding until they
realize what the consequences were then
they will turn against it what and it'll
be a very short period that he will
reign but he's very close to taking over
that
position the number seven and8 is so
interesting in the
Bible if you take David for
example he was the8 son of Jesse so he
has the number
eight but in Chron he's called the
Seventh
Son and so people will say but the Bible
is contradicting itself it can't be both
the eighth and the seventh but if Jesus
is both the eight and the seven and the
eight belongs to the
seven then the
type of Christ must have the same
attributes all very interesting but we
can do a little study of that at the
later stage so we're almost there where
where are we almost we're almost at the
image of the
Beast and we know that the image of the
Beast will be set up before probation
closes we know that for a
fact and then he will reign for a short
while fortunately it is a short while
yeah otherwise no flesh would have been
been alive after yes and uh the last
events will be rapid ones so let's look
at some of I think we're seeing rapid
movements I think we're seeing rapid
movements I'm glad that the pace is
picking up
because uh it's time to go home here's
an article about Madonna now why do we
put something like that in it well a
stage name is Madonna mhm now of course
that's a very interesting name because
uh it has roots in Catholicism yeah and
we know that she often uh uh performs
very blasphemously mhm and yet she has
this strong connection to the system
yeah and with a deity
yes and now it says there bonna believes
she spoke to God during a near-death
hospitalization for serious bacterial
infection and she said there I'm pretty
sure that God was saying to
me do you want to come want to come up
with me me no Madonna
said the interesting thing is that the
mega stars are experiencing or let us
least say portraying a
religiosity
yeah so there's a shift away from a
purely secular to a religious theme
that's and it's a big push especially
with the lent the Catholic lent that
just started we've showed also
previously with Mark Walberg the actor
quite a few actors that are really
saying they found God in this in this
period in this period and now a lot of
them are returning to God you we've got
Madonna saying now this whole thing of
Lent is of course a a Roman Catholic um
ritual let's call it that Jesus fasted
40 days and 40 nights and he his his
ministry was
complete if we have to reperform
everything that he did every time that
is an element of works I'm not saying
that we shouldn't fast but to ritualize
it yeah is to me a a a
distortion of what the scriptures
actually tell us but let's leave that as
it is yeah it's definitely the the push
about this godliness
or getting to know God is really coming
from the entertainment world and we know
that music will play a great part at the
end of time and so many of these Stars
will come out in favor of certain things
that will
transpire because we know that when
everybody has to bow down to the image
of the Beast music will play a very
prominent role m so we can see the
precursors of all of this happening in
the world and then you have the mix of
climate change
yeah which also fits of course into this
agenda and has a religious connotation
oh for sure otherwise the pope wouldn't
be talking about it all the time right
that's it and um also like in the what's
a prophet we did in Brazil we
showed they they negate the the
facts and it's still happening yes and
now you've got in the same one that we
showed there people backtracking on what
they said previously so now you got
Soros and all these companies wanting to
do block out the Sun and stuff so some
of the people that are propagating this
are backtracking on their words like for
instance Bill Gates yes now it's very
interesting Martin
that they they want to blame the
sun uh Canada backs Bill Gates's scheme
to block the
sun well you know martin birds of a
feather flock together don't they so the
government's environmental and climate
change Canada released A Five-Year Plan
for tackling so-called global
warming Environment Canada is also
experimenting with Cloud whitening which
uses sea salt to brighten the clouds
above the ocean to increase
electricity and reduce solar
absorption Gates's radical plan was
officially launched last week as
scientists began pumping chemicals into
the sky the scientists are injecting
reflective particles into the sky
dumping chemicals in the ocean and
spraying salt water in the air in a
desperate effort to stop or reverse
climate change
now when God created
light did he pronounce it
good
yes and on the fourth day of creation
when he
created The
Luminaries that was to sustain the
light which he had already created mhm
and did he pronounce them good yeah now
is it a fact that the scientific World
tells you that sunlight is bad for you
yes they do do they tell you that you
should screen yourself from the sunlight
mhm now do you know Martin that in the
old days things like tuberculosis or
rickets or any one of those
diseases could be cured by uh solar
exposure
yeah so is the sunlight good or is the
sunlight bad I believe that today we can
still cure quite a lot of things if you
just go into the sun spend time in the
sun uh Adam and Eve were they placed in
a garden yes or were they placed under a
roof I don't think there was any roof
all right maybe a canopy of trees but
now if you take these rural people that
work a lot outside in the sun are they
the ones that have the cancer or is it
those that live in the cities and in the
buildings no no under artificial light
MH and you know the rumor you shouldn't
stick your arm out of your car window
you're going to get cancer on that arm
why is it that the other arm is more
likely to get the cancer than the one
that gets the sun exactly so there are a
lot of issues we're not going to talk
about healing powers of the Sun but
sunlight is one of the healing elements
in the New Start
program that's it you need exposure to
the sun eight laws of Health right now
these people want to block the Sun
uh if the Sun is good according to the
scripture blocking the sun is that good
or is it bad definitely not good it's
definitely not good so these people are
pagans and they are working directly
against God's healing elements yeah and
you know what's
actually worse as they they're not only
talking about this they're actually
starting to do this governments are REM
using their so-called
billions that have been fleeced from
people in the world and placed into the
pockets of people who believe that they
are the model conscience of the world I
only have one model barometer and that
is the word of God yeah and that word of
God tells me that I must have a
relationship with God mhm and that my
secular relationship should not be
mingled
with my relationship with God for sure
okay but the fact of the matter is that
everything is connected nothing is is uh
an island in itself no no definitely not
this also like you mentioned before is
linking back to religion yes but what
was interesting is and we'll have a look
at it now is how Bill Gates what what
what's his stand on this what does he
say well let's have a look what he says
so so in closing give us your level of
optimism at this point are we going to
be okay what the there's a lot of
climate exaggeration you know that
climate is not the end of the planet so
the planet's going to be fine uh we're
not going to completely reverse
development so you know when we went
from 10 million kids dying per year in
the year 2000 down to 5 million we're
not going to reverse that it's going to
slow down our progress and so things
like climate adaptation which doesn't
get hardly any uh visibility that's
become very important for the poor
countries and yes it is a burden on them
a significant burden on them that you
know it's not they didn't create the
problem we created the problem so this
is all numbers uh you know will we hit
1.5 deges no will we hit 3° no we'll be
below we'll be in that range the lower
the better and the you know the sense of
progress it's important for people to
see that emissions in many areas have
come down and at least at the lab level
we have economic solutions for every
kind of emission Martin I'm so glad they
have all these economic solutions for
all the world's problems and this Regal
Wei that he is constantly
using uh you might you might as well
just remove him from his chair and put
the pope on that chair because he says
exactly the same things and everybody in
this little boy club uh is doing the
same thing and saying the same thing and
they are all working at Cross purposes
with God yeah all of them and isn't it
disturbing that the governments and
everybody's just jumping on the
bandwagon all right and if you mention
God you get into trouble right oh boy
definitely no Mar this
battle this dichotomy that we are seeing
is our typical north south scenario King
of the North king of the king of the
North King of the South King of the
North has a religio political agenda the
King of the South has a secular agenda
yes so basically we could say that is
this is playing out even in the
political
realm and at the moment it seems as if
the the
south is in the pound
seats they are in many seats of
government but we can see all over the
world like in the elections that you had
in the Netherlands for example or now in
Portugal or in Argentine that the swing
is definitely to the right and the King
of the North is going to come against
this secular mode of thinking and
totally
overrun it according to the scripture
yeah although they're both sitting at
the same table and probably planning
this so to choose a side is ridiculous
because you are choosing the devil in
blue compared to the devil in red and
it's probably no Co coincidence that
those are also the colors of certain
political entities in the United States
of America no definitely not a
coincidence new liberal online homes
build to make online hate punishable up
to life in prison we're going from the
sublime to the ridiculous no no it's I
mean Canada has been for quite a while
at the Forefront of this hate speech
thing but now they take this proposed
bill is taking it to a Next Level yes
there are there are very few leaders in
the
world that uh take things up to the
level of the
ridiculous uh as much as some of these
lead ERS like the Canadians at the
moment for example the federal
government tabled its long awaited
online harms bill on Monday which is
already shaping up to become a delicate
political batom over freedom of
expression on the internet while also
aiming to provide more protections for
children it also amends the criminal
code to create a new Standalone hate
crime offense that would allow penalties
up to life imprison them to deter
hateful conduct now what is hateful
conduct as well as raise the maximum
punishment for hate propaganda offenses
from 5 years to life imprisonment for
advocating genocide now all of these
rules that they come up with will they
rile up another party yes for sure so
isn't this a plan yes just make the
rules so ridiculous that that everybody
says
that's enough enough so Martin if you
quote a Bible verse that doesn't suit
you then you get life imprisonment I
mean that's so ludicrous a few years ago
as they State there it was 5 years
imprisonment for quoting certain Bible
verses I was in Canada once and they
they wanted me to to take a stand on a
certain issue but I also know what the
law
says and we have to sometimes
be a little bit circumspect as to how we
deal with these things and the Bible
tells us to be circumspect so they asked
me what I thought about the
issue and uh it was the
lgbtq plus whatever
issue and I said well it's very simple I
feel what God
feels and they said well what does God
feel I said you you've got a book you
can read it for yourself I don't know
have to tell you and left it at that so
I never quoted a verse I never said
anything and uh uh I didn't get into
trouble maybe they didn't hear about it
whatever but these days those fines of
many thousands of dollars or five years
are now being sought to be increased to
life imprisonment so a murderer a mass
murderer gets set free and some Who
quotes a Bible verse goes to prison
According to some of the proposed
legislation yeah but I think it's just
to make the pendulum swing that's the
only thing to get it to say that is
enough and let's overrun the King of the
South we've been saying it from from the
beginning people will just start saying
enough is enough enough is enough here's
another pointer Brazil's former
president bolsonaro denies coup attempt
as he addresses huge rally what's a coup
tanks in the street weapons conspiracy
none of that happened in Brazil Mr
bolsonaro told an estimated crowd of
185,000 people that filled blocks of sa
Paulo now we were there just
recently and the people told us that
this man has a tremendous popularity
yeah he's going through similar things
as Trump is going through very similar
they even had it there January 8 like
the January 6 a year later all sorts of
things and they're accusing him and
trying to keep him off ballots and what
have you but uh he's a people's person
so when he gets on his
motorbike and he takes a drive then very
soon he's got thousands of bikers and
people following him and they rally in
the streets so the more more they try to
crush him yeah the more he rallies
because the more the support of the
people Gets behind him and that will be
a s okay that's similar to what we see
in America the people are the ones
agitating the swing now Martin if the
same strategy is applied in the United
States as it is here in
Brazil isn't a planned
strategy if you if you look at it with
an eagle's eye view then you can see
what it's too similar aren't they
sitting at the table saying how are we
going to make this happen I believe so
let's tread on this guy and let's make
it so unfair and so ridiculous that
everybody gets riled up MH is that a
possibility well up cow why not create
the chaos so that you can create the
order we know what what they want they
want spiritual power and Satan wants
worship yes that's his aim and he
doesn't care how he's going to get it
no so let's get right into it the second
past of Revelation Revelation
13:14 it deceives them that dwell on the
Earth by means of those Miracles so
there's a relig I Revival that takes
place and this is a very deceptive
religious
revival are we seeing this kind of
religious revival taking place yes
definitely and it had power to do this
in the sight of the Beast so this second
beast the United States of America has
power to implement what the first Beast
actually want
right saying to them that dwell on the
earth this is
legislation or if not legislation for
the own country then coercive tactics in
terms of other countries economic
measures
whatever that they should make an image
to the Beast which had the wound by a
sword and did live so it had to become
like the first
Beast and the first Beast was a religio
political power where the religious
authorities dictated to the state what
should happen yeah and also to enforce
their
dogmas so this second beast the United
States that started as a lambl likee
beast starts talking like a
dragon and the dragon was Rome yes
starts speaking like Rome and Rome gets
its power from the dragon who's also a
symbol of the devil devil yeah and so it
starts enforcing religious dogmas yes so
laws are being written by the state that
is dictated to them by the church
correct and it's doing this in the full
presence of the Beast that received the
deadly wound which is Roman Catholicism
that lost its power in
1798 when their secular power was
removed and the Bible says he's going to
get his secular power back there will be
a resurrection of the
eight and he had power to give life unto
the image of the Beast that the image of
the Beast should both speak he's going
to speak mhm how does he speak through
legislation yes is going to say this is
what's going to happen and he's going to
cause as many as would not worship the
image of the Beast if you don't go along
with
it you will be killed no the law will
say death to you death to you the other
side is saying if you say anything about
religion you're going to go to jail for
life and this side is saying if you
don't listen to my religious Dogma
you're going to be
killed first I'll uh apply a little bit
of economic pressure on you and if you
don't yield you're going to be killed
yeah this is the reality of what the
scripture says yeah and then the next
verse of course tells us that he will
implement the mark of the first piece
mhm and the first she said the mark of
my ecclesiastical power is that I have
transferred the Sabbath to the Sunday
yeah that's that's a pagan Sun worship
that's it it's worship towards the
east now Martin if you go back in
history and you go to the Garden of
Eden uh the Bible tells us that God
planted a garden in the east in the East
of
Eden it was in in the
East and then they were thrown out Adam
and Eve and they were thrown out at the
East
Gate which means they left the
gate of the East and were Facing East
and
left and there was a pair of cherubs
placed at the gate so that they could
not come in and then the Bible tells us
that when Cain
arrived he went further east yeah to
build cities to build cities so the
religion of the East was a religion
facing the East it was Sun
worship of which Sunday was of course
the great day but God said to his people
turn round yeah turn round and face the
West in other words face the Garden of
Eden where the covering cherubs were
which were a symbol of the covering
cherubs that guarded the ark MH so God
said when you worship me turn your back
towards the east when he took Abraham
out
of which was in the East y he had to
cross the river yes which is the
Euphrates and he had to go a land which
is directly west exctly of where he was
saying we had to turn his back on the
East and the temple was built in such a
way mhm that the gate or the entrance
was such that when you looked at it you
were facing west yeah but the people
were always inclined to turn around and
worship towards the east yeah Ezekiel
tells us that the elders had their backs
towards the temple and we're facing the
East yeah so Martin there's a tremendous
propensity for sun worship that's it and
if you worship on a Sunday you are a sun
worshipper still carry on going back and
they're and they're facing the wrong way
and so they even build their churches
the wrong way so that you always face
East rather than west facing west
there's there's no coincidence in any of
these things the fact of the matter is
Jesus will come out of the East and he
will come out of the East yes because
the punishment will come from where they
worship now the interesting thing is
this image of the beast in other words
this political system that started lambl
likee and then becomes prescriptive in
terms of belief
systems this image of the Beast will
arise before probation closes yeah
right and it will
start raising its
voice and it'll speak like the dragon
yeah so it'll speak exactly like the
paper he did in the Middle Ages you
either mhm do as I say or I'll put thumb
screws on you yeah and if you don't
listen I'll put you on the rack and I'll
stretch you longer than you are now yes
I'll make you very
tall and if you don't listen further I
will hand you over to the state to have
you killed yes and I'll be doing all of
this for God all of this I'll do for God
yes Martin this is where we are in the
stream of
history in order to do this you need to
rile up the people M that there must be
a
change and the situation or the status
quo must be so bad that people will want
the change exactly right mhm they it
will be by popular
demand that people want certain things
implemented correct so if we look at uh
the advertisement that Donald Trump puts
out now let's make it quite plain it
doesn't matter whether Donald Trump
wins it doesn't even matter if the
Republicans
win it makes logical sense yes but it
doesn't matter if it doesn't happen
because scripture will be fulfilled with
or without them exactly and if you want
to do it the other way around it's not
impossible because because what what is
uh Biden isn't the Roman Catholic isn't
he one that bows at the feet of the Pope
exactly and they can give all this
legislation going that will also be
religious in its um core but it will be
for climate
change there's lots of ways that this
can plan out but the most logical way
seems to be the Christian nationalist
that would be the most logical so let's
just see what what he has to
say
more than a
country more than a shining City on a
Hill the idea of America lives in each
and every one of
us America
lives but a storm has gathered at our
Shores a tempest that seeks to tear
apart the fabric of our nation it seeks
nothing less than the want and
destruction of this great nation of men
women it seeks to rip out erase and
supplant the very foundations of
practicality and reason it seeks to
erase
us we know this enemy they have existed
throughout time and now they have come
for
us and they have come for our
children we watch the clouds coal less
and gather we watched them form for
decades from a distance as they
approached our
borders we heard the clap of Thunder
echo in our minds and rattle down
through the halls of our capitals we
have most of us become complacent
unaware and
disengaged while the darkness grew and
unfolded around us
slowly then all at
once
this threat is
real what we face is a hurricane of
Deceit and moral Decay with the goal of
absolute power we Face a true battle of
good versus
evil if we stand by and do nothing evil
will
Triumph but that is not our fate we are
great men we are great men with a great
leader a leader that loves this nation
and what it has given back to him a
leader who seeks the same ideals as we
do ideals of Truth liberty and
justice he sees the greatness in us and
the great potential in America and its
future he seeks to make America great
again
this man will guide us but he cannot do
it alone it takes every one of us
alongside him it takes work it takes
faith and it takes
resolve together we can fight this storm
we can fight and we will win unite now
gather alongside him come together for
this nation bear the the colors of red
white and blue that are woven into the
fiber of this nation saturated with a
blood of patriots that came before us
sacrifice your time sacrifice your
effort to rebuild this nation
together together we can save America
the America that lives in all of us
Trump 2024
were there religious elements in that
advertisement I think it was
dominant was it a declaration of war
against the ideology of the South for
sure oh yes for the King of the South
100% so is it uh a fulfillment of Daniel
chapter 11 yeah this is basically the
King of the North overrun the King of
the South he's going to overrun him
completely and the King of the South is
pushing at him oh yeah and he has riled
him up and he's going to come now he
called it a city on a hill actually more
than a city on the hill there is of
course another city on the hill in fact
on Seven Hills and it sits in Rome
yeah that's very fascinating
M and us is capitalized yeah and the
Savior where he stands like the second
coming of Jesus it's all very religious
all right images will Humanity save
Humanity or will only Christ save
humanity and will Christ save Humanity
for an Earthly Kingdom no no it will be
a Heavenly Kingdom so Mar we are living
in very fascinating times
and the conservatives over the world
whether it now be the one in Brazil
who's not in power or the one which is
in arentine who is in power who spoke so
vehemently against the pope and ran to
the pope with fear and trembling bowing
down kissing him leaning over backwards
just to bask in the sunlight of his
acceptance will these birds of a feather
all flocked together it's starting
already for sure is it happening in
Europe the swing to the right is it
happening in the South Americas the
swing to the right let's have a look at
this
SP
president to meet you it's a very big
pleasure to know
you come Argentina great
again y just mentioned a few president
of Argentina who's gotten a lot of
publicity he's gotten a lot he's a great
gentleman you know he's Mega he's Mega
make Argentina great God it's
true day to make the left wi
Shake don't let socialism
Advance is it a declaration of war yeah
for sure from against the King of the
South King of the North is flexing his
muscles he's coming with the economy
he's coming with ships he's coming with
military power MH and he's over running
the King of the South and it is
happening before our eyes and few people
actually see it now let's just make
absolutely sure church and state
together that's the image of the
Beast Donald Trump is he promising to
bring church and state together yes
let's have a look more than ever for
hardworking Americans November 5th will
be our new Liberation day but for the
liars and
cheaters and fraudsters and censors and
Impostors who have commanded our
government it will be their judgment day
their Judgement Day ladies and gentlemen
with your help and God's grace the great
Revival of America begins on November
5th
[Applause]
2024 be able to do it because you're the
people we want to hear from the pastors
and the ministers and the rabbis the
people in this room are the people we
want to hear from and they have to have
a political voice you know if you think
about it you have men you have women and
you have religion if you look at it you
have more than the men you have more
than the women you have such power but
you really you weren't allowed to use
that power and you're now allowed to use
I get in there you're going to be using
that power at a level that you've never
used it before it's going to bring back
the churchgoer I mean you have to see I
don't like the charts when I see charts
where they're going in the wrong
direction we don't like that we're going
to bring it back and I really believe
it's the biggest thing missing from this
country it's the biggest thing missing
we have to bring back our religion we
have to bring back Christianity in this
country and I will fight even harder for
Christians with four more years in the
white house we did things that uh the
likes of which nobody has ever done for
Christians in this country and I'm very
proud of that and honored by it
evangelists like the late great Pat
Robertson who is a great gentleman got
to know him very
well great
evangelist and of course Billy graah how
good was Billy grah
[Music]
right I remember my father took me to
Yankee Stadium and Billy graah was
preaching and it was amazing I was very
young my father loved Billy graah and
that place was packed bigger than any
World Series game bigger than anything
anybody's ever seen and it was packed
and uh we would love to bring it back to
those days Jack right would' love to
bring it back to those days
bazic our country would greatly benefit
by it well Martin irrespective of the
fact that many of those religious
leaders that he mentioned were high
Masons the fact of the matter is they
want to bring the power back to the
church that is the image of the Beast so
Martin these these convocations that
they have like CPAC where church and
state mingle and talk about these issues
now Nigel farage of of England is the
one that was recently in the news about
uh his banking situation where they Clos
these bank accounts
Etc he also believes that the pendulum
is swinging yeah so let's hear what he
has to
say and some media on Saturday Night
Live says what is De banking does it
really exist so we find on the other
side denial at everything we try to
expose and raise but I am hopeful I'm
optimistic that we can get that pendulum
to swing back that we can get that
pendulum to swing back because still in
all of our countries there is a majority
for common sense we might not see that
common
sense if we watch
CNN or read the New York
Times or listen to many on Capitol Hill
but it's the same in every country you
get outside the capital cities and you
find a clear solid majority for common
sense it's interesting that he says
those outside there in the country are
the ones that have the common
sense and uh we'll see that the other
side says that those out there in the
country are the enemy yeah so it's a war
it's a north south war and it's heating
up and the Pendulum he says is going to
swing MH and he says it's going to swing
in all the countries he says so it will
start in the United States and it will
quickly spread to other areas of the
world where people are fed
up with a kind of rule of law that has
been operating over the last decade
that's it and everybody especially when
they're on the conservative side are
very optimistic that the globalists will
be shunned out and and the conservative
religious right will rule again as it
should according to them and Martin it
will be Protestant America yeah actually
secret R secretly run by the Roman
Catholic hierarchy because the whole of
the CIA and all of those are actually KN
of Malta
organizations they will do it in the
United States and in the rest of the
world the papacy will see its research
yeah so it will have a resurrection it
will be the eighth and part of the seven
yeah here's an article in the word and
way Trump promises a Revival of
Christian power in speech to National
Religious
broadcasters if I get in you're going to
be using that power at a level you've
never used it before Trump told the
annual Gathering of National Religious
broadcasters at Nashville Gaylord opery
land Resort and Convention Center he
told the religious broadcasters that one
of his first acts of a second Trump term
would be to set up a task force to root
out anti-christian bias I will be a
peacemaker and I'll be the only
president who can say and I say this
with great conviction I will prevent
World War I we have to bring back our
religion he said we have to bring back
Christianity is he throwing a Lifeline
to Putin yes he is and I believe he's
not saying that very lightly no are they
actually sitting at a table planning
this already for sure and the
threatenings of World War III are they
increasing yes didn't Sweden just join
NATO exactly and didn't uh macron just
say it's time to put boots on the ground
in the Ukraine you he's yeah he said we
cannot rule out that there will be
military men joined correct and didn't
Putin say that this is a red line and
this is leading up to World War III yes
nuclear bombs will fall now why would
they use inflammatory rhetoric to such
an
extent and threaten World War
I just think about it Martin because
they want WR World War I they want to
Stir It Up so that they can be a savior
and there must be a savior who says
enough this is not going to happen right
and he promises he will do that now
Putin is he very much in tune with his
Orthodox Church yes very much the
Ukraine is also in tune with the
Orthodox church although they've chosen
another patriarch yeah they've turned
their back on Russia that's it but
religion will be the unifying factor in
the end and both of those go uh
presidents are very much in with the
pope now
Martin to achieve religious
unity I want you to M this one
over to achieve religious unity wouldn't
it be expedient to have a common enemy
oh for sure always all right pilate and
Herod were enemies
MH and then they found a
commonality there was someone that had
to be condemned but they didn't want to
do it
alone so when they both joined up to
condemn they felt better about each
other so from that day on they became
friends yeah so even supposed enemies
like the Orthodox in Ukraine and the
Orthodox in Russia or or the papacy and
the Orthodox we've seen all the pictures
of all those Patriarchs embracing the
Pope in any case even the Protestants
and all the Protestants now to get them
all to join up wouldn't it be nice to
give them a common enemy yeah what if
there could be someone who says what you
are doing is not lawful you are speaking
against the law of
God and the Orthodox will look at them
and say who's who's this crawling out of
the woodwork over there and the
Protestants will say who are you you
sectarians to tell us that we are not in
harmony with God look at the wonderful
movement we've taken over governments we
are in the seat of power again God is
prospering our Kingdom and who are you
to go against us Miracles will
follow and we have the Miracles on our
side the signs and wonders what do you
have you have the word and the word says
I'm the Lord I change not do not think
that I've have come to abolish the law
not one jot or one title will by any
means pass out of the law if you love me
keep my Commandments who are you to
quote those verses to us when God is
obviously on our side yes we have the
possibility of peace peace for the first
time and we're doing it on a religious
basis and you want to be a thorn in our
flesh away with you the common enemy
would be so useful wouldn't you think so
yeah for sure I think the Bible actually
tells us this will be and you think that
pilot and Herod can become friends again
in an anti-typical sense what they both
ruling parties opposed to each
other well life is
interesting now of course the South
won't sit quietly by no while the King
of the North is mastering his forces to
rush over him like an overwhelming storm
as it's in stated in that advertisement
so this lady from
Politico warned against Christian
nationalism and she received quite a
backlash didn't she yeah no let's hear
what she had to
say hear words like Christian
nationalism like the New Apostolic
Reformation these are groups that you
should get very uh very schooled on
because they have a lot of power in
Trump's Circle and the one thing that
unites all of them because there's many
different groups orbiting Trump but the
thing that re unites them as Christian
nationalists not Christians by the way
because Christian nationalists is very
different is that they believe that our
rights as Americans as all human beings
don't come from any Earthly Authority
they don't come from Congress they don't
come from the Supreme Court they come
from God the problem with that is that
they are determining man men it is men
are determining what God is telling them
and in the past that so-called natural
law is you know it's a pillar of
Catholicism Catholicism for instance
it's been used for good in social
justice campaigns Martin Luther King
evoked it in talking about civil rights
but now you have an extremist element of
conservative Christians who say that
this applies specifically to issues
including abortion gay marriage and it's
going much further than
[Music]
that
Martin what you said was actually spot
on it actually it is isn't that
interesting but how did the others react
how did the Christians react yes let's
have a look well here's an article from
Fox News by the way Fox News is now the
the most watched news organization in
the United States yes they are but also
noteworthy is they are mainly
Catholic of course so Christian groups
sent letter to Politico demanding
apology of a reporters viral comments as
deeply
disturbing prominent Christian group
sent a letter to Politico demanding an
apology for what they call the smearing
of the Christian faith following
comments made by one of its top
reporters so Perkinson Birch knocked
this reporter for not acknowledging our
own report public was founded on the
belief that our rights come from God not
Earthly Kings or governments citing the
Declaration of Independence the letter
continued setting aside the inaccuracy
of her commentary she was manifestly
trying to demonize the Christian
Community and so fear through propaganda
is there a war on oh I don't think you
can deny this anymore so you cannot deny
it modernly this comes to fruition do we
have the image of the Beast set up yeah
the image of the Beast is set up prior
to probation closing mhm so we're very
very close to the end right there we're
right
there so M this King of the North
philosophy is to overrun the King of the
South
philosophy and the way to do that is to
bring religion and state together and
enforce dogmas that will totally
eradicate the other way of thinking
right yes yes let's see what Alex Jones
who is very prominent on the side
of this conservative thinking what he
has to say when you tell your brain a
lie or to not be honest you're really
lying to yourself and then you start
using all this brain capacity to figure
out the lie and to then try to project
things to cover up the LIE when you get
into
a I'm at a neurotic level tell the
through people I go in the air talk bad
about myself and bad things I people say
why is he doing that because the more I
do it the more my brain cleans out and
now it's just laser focused and now I
know things much clearer and so it's
like removing computer viruses and and
so when you get the point of just not
lying I mean I mean I used to tell lies
every day leftist tell lies continually
the thing is you go to The Other Extreme
all you do is tell lies so when when you
start moving away from lies you get to
the point where well I told one lie this
week and that was terrible because it's
robbing from you not just people you're
lying to so I've got to the point of
almost zero lying and uh it's it's it's
super empowering and again it's cleaning
out your computer to where your brain
can then operate not worrying about
telling lies it can just say what's
accurate that's amazing I I sense
strongly sense that what you're what you
just said is is the key to everything to
tell the truth period no matter
what it is and and then that means
sometimes it's painful because I don't
want to Hur people's feelings but at the
end of the day we just got to say this
you know I mean we got to say it now
Martin this battle between North and
South
thinking really is at a climax and at
the recent State of the Union Address uh
Joe Biden made it his business to be
very attacking in terms of the
philosophy of the Trump Camp yes and we
will see that uh many of the people will
say from the right will say that what he
said was a total Distortion that's where
um The Alex Jones comment came in
because they were both commenting on the
State of Union address and the lies and
the lies yes that are propagated in a
very loud voice and what to do about the
lies we'll see that he later comments
and says that the only way to get rid of
the lies is to get rid of that
philosophy in its entirety right
mhm and uh this is very very interesting
because it shows this tremendous Clash
that is taking place it's BR a brutal
Clash at this and if you read Daniel 11
carefully you will see that The Final
Storm of the King of the North against
the King of the South is a very
concentrated rapid event yeah yeah and
we are told that the last events will be
rapid ones so there will be a tremendous
rush and for a short time the image of
the Beast will be set up yeah as a
consequence of the image of the Beast
being set up and the Beast beginning to
speak like a
dragon other nations will be infected MH
and that other Beast that first Beast
will experience a resurrection in the
first world yeah
yeah and then prophecy will have been
fulfilled and it will be like you said
it will be
so rapid that you might be caught of God
if you don't have oil if you don't
listen and see what is happening so
let's listen to what they said and some
of the discussions around it and just
the facial expressions of the Speaker of
the House for example in the background
tells you what he's thinking yeah he
must be thinking this is the most
embarrassing situation I've sat through
and I cannot tolerate the lies
yeah look it's a decision to overturn Ro
Wade the Supreme Court majority wrote
The Following and with all due respect
justices women are not without electoral
electoral
power excuse me electoral or political
power you're about to realize just how
much you get
[Applause]
about clearly
clearly those bragging about overturning
riewe have no clue about the power of
women but they found out when
reproductive Freedom was on the ballot
we won in 2022 and 2020 and we're will
again in
2024 why are white rural voters a threat
to democracy at this point you would
think as we pointed out looking at Joe
Biden's background and Donald Trump's
that that the opposite would be true I
mean we lay out the four-fold
interconnected threat that white World
voters pose to the country first of all
and we show 30 polls in National studies
to demonstrate this so we provide the
receipts in chapter six they are the
most racist xenophobic anti-immigrant
anti-gay geodemographic group in the
country second they're the most
conspiracist group qinon support and
subscribers election denialism Co
denialism and scientific skepticism
Obama birtherism third anti-democratic
sentiments they don't believe in an
independent press Free Speech they're
most likely to say the President should
be able to act unilaterally without any
checks from Congress or the courts or
their bureaucracy they're also the most
strongly white nationalist and white
Christian nationalist he said white
four shots and so it's real simple that
MSNBC talking point from 10 years ago
that all Republicans are racist they're
trying to cify into law and then Define
racist as anyone that doesn't want to
give up their cows or their Farm or be a
slave what they're threatened by if
self-sufficient people because it's a
military takeover by the left and and
and by The Who and we talked about this
when I was on three or four months ago
on your show out of Maine they they are
literally understanding we've got the
city we're about to take the dollar
we're collapsing the Border who is the
opposition and they're already lazing
the Target that it's the rural people
remember I said next it's get the rurals
they're the enemy and now that talking
point is everywhere I probably saw that
clip 30 times the last week 50 times the
last month and and and then that's their
next Target just like when linen and
trosky and Stalin took over just Moscow
and a few cities took them five years to
take over Russia who was the target the
farmers because they produce the food
and if you get them now you've got
everybody so they're doing a as you did
a few weeks ago with that incredible
lady a malice SL stalinist linen
Playbook because it works and and so
this is happening this isn't a question
this is going down so Martin it is very
clear that you have two ideologies that
are
clashing and blatantly I mean blatantly
and the president of the United States
takes on the Supreme
Courts openly in front of them in front
of them their their decisions that
they've done it shows you there's a
there's a conflict there's a massive
conflict so M all that's left is to link
the Sabbath with the issue again mhm and
then we have the full picture as
depicted in the scripture including the
mark of the beast right so let's listen
to what this European Parliament member
has to say in in connection with church
and the economic
World dear ladies and gentlemen I'm
happy to support the important work of
the free Sunday Alliance in my eyes uh
free Sunday is not only important from
the Christian Perspective it's uh also
important from a Yung beim perspective
here on the European level we are
discussing a lot about uh how to tackle
loneliness how uh to deal with the
challenges of work life balance uh how
to find answers uh on the question of a
right to disconnect I think these are
all issues directly connected to your
work as a free Sunday Alliance so I'm
looking very much forward to our future
cooperation in this important
[Music]
issues
but let's just to show that this issue
uh crosses continental divides they're
pushing for the um European Sunday
Alliance and they've got every year on
the 3rd of March which is the um
anniversary of Constantine's edict that
he bring brought out in
321 for Sunday legislation they just
commemorating it and just pushing it in
Europe the whole time and they want to
talk about these issues now here's the
buck County
Beacon and it says there's a shocking
online Manifesto which reveals project
2025 link to coordinated Christian
nationalism project now we've been
talking about uh
2025 and this document for a very long
time approximately 100 right-wing
organiz ations have signed onto project
2025 an expansive plan for controlling
and in some cases dismantling federal
agencies in the event that Trump or
another Republican wins the presidential
election this
year Under The Heading big picture the
manifesto claims to affirm that this
Christian nationalist project entails
National recognition of essential
Christian
Orthodoxy as a Christian consensus under
Jesus Christ the Supreme Lord and king
of all creation and the establishment of
the general Equity of the Ten
Commandments as the foundational law of
the nation that's a fascinating
statement when they talk about the Ten
Commandments are they talking about
God's Commandments or Pap Commandments
yeah it will definitely be papal
Commandments it'll be papal Commandments
the Beast it'll be the beasts
prerogative so Martin are we heading for
an Earth's Sabbath yeah I think we're to
appease the secular people as well yes
and are we heading for a beast Sabbath
yeah to appease the religious world yes
and will both of them come into conflict
with people that are people of the book
and keep the Commandments of God rather
than the Commandments of men yes so will
there be a common enemy oh for sure well
there you have it
so the secular world will be happy the
religious world will be happy and the
only dissenting voice will be that small
little group that warns against the mark
of the beast yeah now this article from
us Catholic is very enlightening it came
from
2024 February the 2 and it talks about a
documentary about Reviving the Sabbath
and it says as the documentary shows the
Puritans brought an especially rigorous
and Rous observation of the Sunday
Sabbath to American
Shores there's no such thing as a Sunday
Sabbath by the way and in this their
cultural influence outlasted their
doctrinal dominance well into the mid
20th century laws requiring businesses
to close on Sunday were common in the
United States in fact in one of Sabbath
most surprising segments we learned that
Bergen County New Jersey a New York City
suburb has Sunday closing to this very
day in 1993 a referendum the County's
residents upheld the Sunday regulation
by a 2:1 vote and then this fascinating
statement Sabbath may be
personal but it is never
individual it's an observance that a
community does to together and one that
has clear implications for the making of
a just and sustainable social order
Martin it's not a personal choice
according to them you may not make the
choice they'll make it for you it's for
the common good for the common good is
that what the Bible says oh yes will
everybody be forced to adhere to it
because of the common good mhm what if
it's against God's law sorry sorry they
still do it economic sanctions yeah
death decree
all of that plagues exactly
fortunately there are seven angels with
seven balls full of plagues yeah but
it's a it's a very serious situation and
the world will have to make a choice
very very soon mhm we are closer than we
think I think so too let's pray it's
right on the
edge Heavenly Father the image of the
Beast is
forming once it has been
established probation lingers for a very
short
while and this is the only time in which
to reach
Humanity because when that
closes the plagues
fall and those that are declared just
will remain just and those that are
declared unrighteous will remain
unrighteous a very short window of
opportunity to make a
choice help us to make the choice clear
is my prayer in jesus' name amen
amen the Lord is open the way in a
remarkable manner for his people to give
the warning message to those who have
never yet heard the truth for this
time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
h
on the H for ways stood in all Ro
cross the EM of
suffering and I love that old cross with
the
dearest and best for a world of
lost was
SL so
the old
bled till
my last I
[Music]
down
I to the old Dr
cross and
exchange
for
[Music]
possible to pleas
him and that's a terrible statement it
is impossible to please God if you do
not believe him
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
e
[Music]
oh
for
[Music]
oh glorious love of Christ my Lord
Divine that made him sto to save a soul
like
mine through all my days and then in
Heaven
above
my song will silence never I'll worship
him
forever and praise him for his glorious
[Music]
love
h do you
believe that God is calling
you to step
out run a in front of your armor
bearers because you've so fully put your
trust in
God
[Music]
[Applause]
how are you thank
youor you want to hear the
song
[Music]
h
okay welcome to a special episode of
WhatsApp
Prof
Professor hello
Walter hello Scotty
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
I
[Music]
nowes
we
[Music]
is
take
[Music]
God
might
[Music]
the reason why we fight the
battle is because our face reflects the
face of
Jesus and no matter how evil they are
out there we have compassion on them and
want them in the kingdom of God
[Music]
for
I
[Music]
the Everlasting gospel to preach to them
that dwell on the earth to every tribe
Kindred to Every Nation Kindred tribe
and
people saying with a loud voice do you
know what loud means this is important
you
the Lord is my
[Music]
salvation the Lord my strength
and who is like
the of
Mercy
who guides with love
[Music]
so the Lord will
rain
[Music]
forever
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
we are living in the last days and there
is a large work to be done among the
people of all languages therefore Every
Soul that believes the truth of this
time whatever his country or speech
should have an intelligent knowledge of
the truth of the third Angel's message
that he may be able to do an intelligent
work for
[Music]
[Applause]
God
[Music]